pardon vous présidez Lana depuis 2020 et
vous êtes également mère de Chambéry
depuis la même année auparavant
auparavant vous étiez président du
Conseil supérieur de la construction et
de l'efficacité énergétique et vous avez
été ministre délégué à la formation
professionnelle et à l'apprentissage
ainsi que ministre aux Affaires
européennes au cours du mandat de
François Hollande enfin vous êtes
familier du lieu puisque vous avez été
sénateur à deux reprises une première
fois entre 2004 et 2012 et la seconde en
madame manquerait Taylor vous avez été
nommé directrice générale de Lana en
2018 vous travaillez auparavant dans le
cabinet du ministre de la cohésion du
territoire et vous êtes architecte
urbaniste en chef de l'État votre
président et votre direction madame
monsieur ont été marqués par la mise en
œuvre en 2020 de la transformation du
crédit d'impôt transition énergétique le
cite en la prime de transition
énergétique mieux connue sous le nom de
ma prime rénov dans la distribution est
assurée par Lana dans la continuité des
programmes habité mieux ma prime rénove
subventionne des travaux de rénovation
énergétique pour les ménages avec une
aide moduler selon les revenus outre le
dispositif de base il existe également
ma prime rénov sérénité qui finance des
opérations de rénovation globale pour
les ménages modestes et ma prime rénove
copropriété à destination des de
copropriétaire il est indéniable que ma
prime rénove connaît un succès populaire
000 primes ont été attribués sur la
seule période de janvier à août 2022 et
le nom m'a prime rénove est désormais
bien connu d'une grande partie de nos
concitoyens ma prime rénove est
rapidement devenue la politique phare de
la rénovation énergétique des logements
privés cependant la prime fait aussi
l'objet de nombreuses critiques et
interrogations qui sont au cœur de notre
commission d'enquête s'il y a bien 700
000 rénovations grâce aux dispositif il
ne s'agit pas de rénovation globale
c'est toute la différence et sans être
réductrice l'objet notre commission
d'enquête Lana indique ainsi que le
nombre de rénovations globale financée
était de 66 000 en 2022
en prenant en compte ma prime rénove
sérénité auquel il faut ajouter le petit
nombre de sel effectuées par ma prime
rénove copropriété les chiffres pour le
dispositif de base qui concentre la
majorité des financements sont encore
plus faibles un indicateur de
performance rattachée au plan de relance
indique ainsi que seul
2200 logements sont sortis des classes F
et G grâce à ma prime rénove sur un
objectif de 80000 certes il ne s'agit
que du nombre de ceux qui ont fait des
démarches pour obtenir un bonus de
subventions mais la réalité est-elle
significativement différente de
nombreuses personnes auditionnées dans
le cadre de cette commission d'enquête
ont ainsi accusé ma prime rénove de trop
favoriser la rénovation par geste au
détriment des rénovations globales
à cet égard il est en effet estimé que
80% des rénovations permissent par la
prime sont des rénovations monégestes
dont essentiellement des changements de
chauffage estimez-vous qu'il faille
progressivement conditionné l'octroi de
la prime à la réalisation de travaux de
rénovation globale ma prime rénove a
également fait l'objet de critiques au
niveau des démarches requises pour
bénéficier de l'aide en particulier la
Défenseur des droits a rendu en octobre
2022 une décision qui fait état de
dysfonctionnement aux conséquences
lourdes pour les usagers parmi les
griefs qui ont été soulevés à l'encontre
du dispositif les dégrèvements d'impôts
ne seraient pas prise en compte pour
apprécier la situation fiscale des
personnes alors que la DGFiP aurait
indiqué que ces techniques
et des usagers ne seraient pas parvenus
à enregistrer leur demande avant le
début de leurs travaux malgré qu'ils
aient entamé leur démarche des moins
auparavant
quelle réponse apportez-vous aux
critiques de la Défenseur des droits ou
en êtes-vous du règlement des dossiers
problématiques depuis votre audition
devant la commission des affaires
économiques du Sénat ici même en
décembre dernier enfin des controverses
ont porté sur la fraude à la rénovation
énergétique les arnaques étaient
courantes lors de la mise en place du
dispositif si bien que le démarchage
téléphonique pour la rénovation a été
interdit par la loi du 24 juillet 2020
pouvez-vous faire un état des lieux en
la matière et nous expliquer le rôle de
l'ANAH dans la lutte contre la fraude
ces séries de difficultés montrent
l'importance de l'accompagnement des
ménages à la rénovation énergétique de
leur logement depuis son lancement le
1er janvier 2022 Lana est ainsi chargée
du pilotage de France rénov un service
public de conseils et d'orientation sur
les travaux de rénovation par ailleurs
un arrêté du 30 décembre 2022 définit
les missions et les conditions
d'agrément des accompagnateurs rénovs
qui ont vocation à devenir une pièce
maîtresse de ce service public toutefois
le clair qui est le réseau pour la
transition énergétique que nous avons
auditionné la semaine dernière indique
que ce service public manque encore de
visibilité et de pérennité son
financement ne serait pas garanti
au-delà du 31 décembre 2023
pensez-vous que le service public de
rénovation de l'habitat est à la hauteur
des enjeux quel serait selon vous les
pistes d'amélioration avant de vous
laisser la parole pour répondre à ses
premières questions et pour un propos
introductif d'une vingtaine de minutes
il me revient de vous indiquer que cette
audition est diffusée en direct et en
différé sur le site internet du Sénat et
qu'un compte rendu sera publié je dois
également vous rappeler qu'un faux
témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête serait passible des peines
prévues aux articles
434-13
434-14 et 434-15 du code pénal qui
peuvent aller de trois ans à 7 ans
d'emprisonnement et de 45000 à 100000
euros d'amende je vous invite donc
Madame la Directrice Générale monsieur
le Président a prêté serment de dire
toute la vérité rien que la vérité a
levé la main droite et à dire je le jure
je vous en remercie donc on va vous
laisser maintenant la parole et ensuite
bien sûr le rapporteur vous posera un
certain nombre d'autres questions ainsi
que nos collègues qui assistent à
l'audition c'est à vous
merci madame
la présidente monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs je vais avant de
venir sur
des questions précises que vous avez
posées vous donnez
entendu un peu générique et de savoir
dans quelle situation effectivement nous
sommes aujourd'hui au moment où nous
sommes devant cette commission d'enquête
je me présente donc avec Madame Valérie
macretolor à la tête de cet agence qui
est agence qui effectivement j'ai
l'honneur de présider depuis 3 ans et
qui s'engage depuis 50 ans en fait au
côté des manèges modestes et des
collectivités territoriales pour
améliorer l'habitat de nos concitoyens 5
choses peut-être sur lesquelles je
souhaite insister plus que jamais la
transition énergétique des logements
passe par la rénovation du parc de
logements existant
car je veux redire ici ce que j'avais
déjà dit elle devant la commission
80% des logements de 2050
existe déjà la rénovation énergétique
est donc au coeur de l'actualité ça
touche à des questions de pouvoir
d'achat de sobriété énergétique de
dérèglement climatique et Lana donc est
au cœur de ces enjeux accompagne chaque
Français sur le chemin de la rénovation
énergétique grâce au déploiement vous
l'avez dit de France Renov nous y
reviendrons et au succès car on doit
parler de succès de ma prime rénov mais
nous apporterons là aussi des éléments
d'ores et déjà l'État met des moyens
inédits pour soutenir cette politique
publique
4,2 milliards d'euros dont un milliard
et demi en aide à la pierre
contractualisée avec les collectivités
que ce soit primorenave sérénité ou ma
prime rénov copropriété ce qui est assez
inédit et qui permet d'obtenir des
résultats en constante progression
les territoires aussi et les acteurs
économiques ont besoin de stabilité
réglementaires et budgétaires pour
continuer de déployer cette politique
publique efficacement et dans la durée
la deuxième chose m'imprime rénove c'est
une première étape dont la réussite se
mesure au nombre de ménages qui ont
sollicité cette aide et qui nous disent
car ce sont aussi les retours qu'à 82 %,
ils sont satisfaits et que 53% des
ménages qui en ont bénéficié nous disent
qu'il n'aurait pas fait de travaux s'il
n'avait pas eu accès à cette
accompagnement cette aide publique a
permis je crois de lancer une dynamique
forte de massification des travaux de
rénovation énergétique et depuis 2020
c'est pas si vieux que cela plus d'un
million et de mines de ménages en ont
bénéficié et d'abord les plus modestes
68% des allocataires des bénéficiaires
de ma prime rénove se situe dans les
quatre premiers des cils les plus
modestes de la population la cible
sociale qui était une cible de ce
produit est effectivement atteinte et
elle a permis cette prime au
bénéficiaire de s'inscrire donc
rapidement dans un parcours de
rénovation
vertueux avec la réalisation d'un
premier geste et ainsi introduit
massivement la décarbonation des
logements privés je veux dire aussi un
chiffre c'est que la moyenne
d'économies conventionnelle d'énergie
finale par logement et par an et passer
de 3,9 mégawattheure avec le cite qui
préexistait à 5,6 mégawh avec MPR ce qui
fait une augmentation
de gains en quelque sorte de
consommation de 44% l'ensemble des
rénovations énergétique soutenue par
l'agence depuis 2020 là aussi c'est très
récent ont permis une économie de
12,2 térawattheure soit la consommation
annuelle des habitants de la ville de
Paris et Lyon cumulée
ces éléments de satisfaction ne nous
font pas oublier que pour certains
usagers le parcours demande peut être
plus compliqué la Défenseur des droits a
pu faire part de dysfonctionnements dont
lui ont fait part certains usagers qui
concernent selon elles près de 500
dossiers vous nous avez fait part dedans
votre questionnaire de certains points
tout à fait précis et nous y reviendrons
dans vos questions nous sommes
conscients des situations que cela
entraîne pour les usagers et au-delà des
dossiers signalés par la Défenseur des
droits nous avons mis en place au sein
de l'agence
une équipe pluridisciplinaire spécifique
créé à cet effet pour suivre ces
dossiers et je peux vous indiquer que la
nappe prend attache individuellement
avec chacune des personnes affectées et
les accompagne dans la prise dans la
reprise de leur parcours la troisième
chose la rénovation la performance dans
la performance est un sujet qui est
souvent revenu lors de votre commission
la rénovation globale c'est la
rénovation idéale personne ne peut le
contester et atteindre des niveaux
ambitieux c'est aussi notre conviction
je dois dire néanmoins qui a pas de
solution unique
ni de recette miracle pour les ménages
qui doivent faire un choix technique et
financier majeur et il est dangereux
d'opposer rénovation globale et
rénovation par jesk car infini il faut
offrir au ménage des choix faire du
sur-mesure chaque dossier est un cas
particulier en fonction de leurs besoins
de leurs moyens on est dans de la
couture au cas par cas et ma primranov
permet une réponse à chaque situation
qu'on soit propriétaire
occupant propriétaire bailleur en copro
soit pour la rénovation par geste ou
globale en complément le traitement des
ménages en situation de fortes précarité
énergétique peut aussi engendrer des
coûts majeurs pour remettre en état des
logements
on pense au sujet d'habitat indigne
dégradé dont les coûts de remise en état
dépassent en moyenne 60000 euros par
logement et l'agence apporte également
des solutions de financement pour ces
situations à travers des opérations de
lutte contre l'habitat indigne à travers
la RHI ou la thyroïde quatrième chose
depuis
[Musique]
2011 Lana accompagné 600 000
propriétaires modestes vers des
rénovations globales dans le cadre de
nos programmes notamment qui par le
passé s'appelait habiter mieux dont 176
000 rénovations c'est trois dernières
années la dynamique est présente elle
est puissante elle continuera à prendre
de l'ampleur cette année notons aussi
les questions liées ma prime rénov
copropriété qui progresse chaque année
malgré un contexte de deux années de
crise sanitaires qui n'ont pas été sans
conséquence puisque beaucoup
d'assemblées générales de
copropriétaires n'ont plus se tenir dans
les conditions normales mais je veux
dire 7000 logements en 2020 12000 en 21
25000 en 22 on voit qu'on est sur une
reprise notamment une peut-être une
prise de conscience dans les
copropriétés cinquième point de mon
propos face à des enjeux énergétiques et
climatiques qui sont sans précédent je
crois que notre réussite ne pourra
qu'être collective 80% je le redis des
logements de 2050 existent déjà nous
devons être tous mobilisés pour rénover
à commencer par l'État qui a fait la
rénovation énergétique des logements
privés et des bâtiments publics un axe
prioritaire du plan de France relance
avec près de 6 milliards 200 millions
d'euros affectés nous en avons fait une
priorité et avant débloquer des moyens
sans précédent pour ce faire nous devons
et savons pouvoir compter sur les
collectivités locales leurs élus qui
sont déjà très fortement engagés sur la
transition écologique dans leur
territoire en favorisant la rénovation
des logements en luttant aussi contre
l'artificialisation des sols en
permettant la réputation de friche
elle joue un rôle moteur dans le
déploiement de France Renov le nouveau
service public de la rénovation de
l'habitat partout sur le territoire et
au plus près du terrain ensemble nous
devons nous accompagner toujours plus de
français dans des parcours de rénovation
performantes grâce à la mobilisation de
nos partenaires et des collectivités et
l'expertise des accompagnateurs renovs
chaque Français peut désormais
bénéficier de conseils qui sont gratuits
qui sont des conseils fiables qui sont
des conseils indépendants au plus près
de son domicile pour démarrer en
confiance des travaux de rénovation
énergétique de son logement
c'est aussi la nécessité d'avoir une
mobilisation de toute la filière de la
rénovation énergétique et nous devons
l'entraîner dans cet élan en l'aidant à
recruter à former toujours plus de
professionnels partout sur le territoire
et aussi à mieux se structurer quand on
banque elles ont aussi un rôle essentiel
à jouer pour financer les restes à
charge et faire en sorte que cela ne
soit pas un obstacle à la rénovation
elles pourront notamment s'appuyer sur
le dispositif incitatif comme les
coprées à zéro ou le prêt avance
rénovation mais je suis sûr que c'est un
sujet dont vous aurez à parler peut-être
même dans l'après-midi aujourd'hui je
pense pouvoir dire qu'il y a une
dynamique sans précédent qui est lancée
on a besoin de la mobilisation de tous
pour être au rendez-vous dans une
dynamique qui est incontestable ce qui
n'empêche pas qu'il y a certainement
encore des améliorations à apporter dans
une politique dont on voit l'explosion
et qui nécessite du coût des adaptations
en permanence c'est Madame la Directrice
générale il revient plus précisément
merci merci madame la présidente
monsieur le rapporteur alors je pense
que je vais prendre tout simplement dans
l'ordre des questions que vous nous avez
adressé si cela vous convient je pense
que c'est le meilleur moyen de d'être le
plus exhaustif possible par rapport aux
questions que vous avez soulevé donc à
la première question relative aux
réussite de ces derniers années
principaux échecs juste bien précisé que
nous intervenons dans le cadre de
l'habitat privé parce que la question
était très centrée sur la rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments donc nous
intervenons que sur le logement et le
logement au statut privé ainsi que le
président de l'ANAH l'a dit cette
politique rénovation énergétique connaît
donc de profondes évolutions je pense
qu'il est important aussi de partager
avec vous tous c'est profondes
évolutions depuis une dizaine d'années
il a bien rappelé que au travers du
programme habité mieux plus de 600 000
rénovations globales avait pu être
financée ce qui est tout à fait
important et donc 176
000 rénovations globales sur ces trois
dernières années comprenant donc
effectivement le changement
d'appellation de ce programme habitait
mieux en ma prime rénov sérénité
2020 a été marqué effectivement comme
vous le rappeliez madame la Présidente
par le déploiement de ma prime rénov qui
a marqué un basculement en fait et une
accélération en transformant en fait une
aide fiscale donc le crédit d'impôt
transition énergétique en une aide
directe à l'attention donc des ménages
une aide qui a été ouverte en 2020 et
qui était essentiellement centrée en
2020 sur les ménages modestes et très
modestes et qui sous l'effet du plan de
relance à compter de la fin de l'année
2020 et très précisément à compter du
début de l'année 2021 c'est ouvert en
fait à tous les ménages tous les
propriétaires occupants quel que soit
leur condition de ressources toutes les
copropriétés quelle que soit les
conditions de ressources des
propriétaires qui
qui forment le conseil syndical de ses
copropriétés et quel que soit la
situation de ses copropriétés et puis
ensuite à partir de l'été 2021 ouverture
à tous les propriétaires bailleurs
c'est-à-dire ceux leur logement et donc
une aide qui couvre vraiment l'ensemble
de l'habitat privé sans faire de
distinguer entre les niveaux de
ressources ou le type de propriétaire ni
le type de copropriété c'est ainsi qu'en
3 ans Lana comptabilise désormais plus
de 1,5 millions de ménages qui ont pu
être accompagnés
de rénovation ce qui correspond à plus
de 7 milliards d'aides versées et qui
correspond aussi à 21 milliards d'euros
de travaux générés grâce à ses aides
publiques donc c'est ce résultat ainsi
que que je le précisais en prenant la
parole montre le chemin parcouru un
chemin et je tiens aussi à le partager
avec vous un chemin qui se construit
encore c'est à dire que c'est une
politique publique qui est jeune et qui
peut connaître connaît d'ailleurs chaque
année des évolutions récentes tout
simplement parce que nous sommes dans
une politique qui a besoin de s'adapter
aux attentes des citoyens aussi parce
que une loi récente a été votée par le
Parlement la loi climat résilience et
puis parce qu'on a un contexte européen
international qui peut avoir aussi
évidemment des impacts à un moment donné
je pense notamment aux effets de
l'inflation par exemple sur le montant
des travaux et cette inflation qui a
fait l'objet déjà de prise en
considération dans l'évolution des aides
depuis le début de l'année 2023 pour ne
citer que cette évolution assez récente
mais j'aurais pu citer aussi le plan
résilience qui a été mis en oeuvre
l'année dernière donc voilà une un point
vraiment important une transformation
très en profondeur une aide fiscale qui
se transforme en une lettre directe et
puis une aide relativement récente mais
qui pour autant vous l'avez d'ailleurs
pointer dans votre introduction madame
la Présidente
montre un véritable succès mais qui
s'améliore encore au fil du temps alors
le point important aussi à prendre en
compte c'est la prise de conscience la
prise de conscience des citoyens qui qui
réel parce que les aides de l'agence
sont évidemment des aides qui sont
sollicitées très fortement par les
citoyens et cette prise de conscience
elle se fait par l'action citoyenne bien
évidemment mais elle se fait aussi au
travers des territoires et j'y
reviendrai tout à l'heure quand on
parlera de France rénove mais il faut
avoir en tête que le nombre d'opérations
programmées d'améliorations de l'habitat
et le nombre de programmes d'intérêt
général qui sont contractualisés entre
l'agence et les collectivités
territoriales ne fait que croître
pendant le même laps de temps c'est à
dire depuis 2020 montrons bien montrant
bien que le les élus locaux et les
collectivités territoriales sans
s'engage de plus en plus dans des
politiques locales de l'habitat en
faveur de l'habitat privé notamment donc
une autre un point évidemment qui est
important c'est que cette politique
publique s'inscrit comme je le précisais
dans un temps long elle doit s'adapter
en permanence donc à certaines
situations et au contexte et notamment
en cette année 2023 elle doit s'adapter
à une disposition de la loi climat
résilience qui est la mise en place donc
de du dispositif mon accompagnateur
rénov qui est effectivement le 1er
janvier de cette année et qui
est effectivement pour l'ensemble des
acteurs historiques qui réalisent déjà
de l'accompagnement donc ce sont toutes
les équipes de suivi animation qui sont
désignés par les collectivités
territoriales dans le cadre des opas et
des programmes d'intérêt généraux et ce
sont bien sûr tous les espaces conseils
France rénov qui réalisent déjà des
actes d'accompagnement et ensuite on
ouvre bien entendu d'ici quelques
semaines l'agrément pour permettre à de
nouveaux acteurs de pouvoir s'engager
dans cette démarche de façon à
démultiplier le nombre d'accompagnateurs
possibles sur le territoire l'objectif
et c'est un des points aussi importants
que nous souhaitions partager avec vous
c'est de mettre en place de la confiance
en fait vis-à-vis des ménages les
ménages en ont cruellement besoin pour
pouvoir s'engager en fait dans des
démarches de travaux les plus
les ambitieuses possibles pour pouvoir
améliorer donc leur logement donc voilà
un peu les éléments principaux en
réponse à la question numéro 1 la
question numéro 2 vous évoquiez qu'elle
pouvait être les freins à cette
politique de recommandation énergétique
je pense que ce que le président de Lana
a pointé c'est que la et qui est très
important c'est que finalement c'est une
politique qui concerne tout le monde qui
concerne environ 20 millions de ménages
ces ménages appartiennent à toutes
sortes de catégories sociales
ont évidemment des envies plus ou moins
importantes de s'engager dans des
démarches de travaux se posent de
multiples questions sur les types de
travaux qu'ils doivent réaliser donc sur
l'état de leur logement donc il est très
important de pouvoir bénéficier d'un
diagnostic de qualité de pouvoir aussi
être mis en contact avec des entreprises
de qualité et donc la question de
l'accompagnement est évidemment centrale
elle va être mise en œuvre de façon
obligatoire et généralisée pour des
rénovations à partir d'un certain
montant de travaux et donc à partir d'un
certain montant de subventions et
évidemment pour toutes les rénovations
globales et par ailleurs je le partage
avec cette commission aujourd'hui comme
nous l'avions partagé avec la commission
des affaires économiques un travail
important a été mis en place déjà depuis
plusieurs années pour faire converger
l'ensemble des aides qui existent
puisque ma prime rénov n'est pas la
seule aide existante il existe bien
entendu les aides de l'État autour de ma
prime rénov les certificats d'économie
d'énergie et les aides des collectivités
territoriales et donc il est extrêmement
important de pouvoir faire converger
quand je parle de convergence c'est
aligner l'ensemble des critères qui
permettent aux ménage de bénéficier de
l'ensemble de ces aides sur la base d'un
même objectif leur permettant évidemment
d'avoir ensuite de pouvoir bénéficier en
fait de l'ensemble de ces aides et
d'être mieux solvabilisés c'est-à-dire
d'avoir le reste à charge le plus faible
possible lorsqu'il s'engage dans ce
programme
de travaux pour leur logement qu'il
s'agisse de logement en de mes logements
en besoin individuel ou en habitat
collectif
en question numéro 3 vous nous
interrogiez vous nous interrogez
d'ailleurs sur la lutte contre la fraude
dans le cadre de la rénovation
énergétique et les limites de cette
politique de lutte contre la fraude et
nous recommandations alors il y est il
est très important de pouvoir distinguer
deux choses nous semble-t-il la première
c'est de bien distinguer la fraude de
l'escroquerie en fait l'a fraude est une
sont des pratiques ou une pratique qui
très organisée je vais le formuler de
cette manière là qui consiste à usurper
des identités d'usagers
usurper des identités d'entreprise et
entrer de façon plus ou moins massive
dans des systèmes d'information et donc
sur des plateformes de demandes d'aide
publique pas uniquement en matière de
rénovation énergétique des des demandes
en fait qui derrière lesquels qui
ressemblent d'ailleurs enfin qui sont
parfaitement
correctes en fait mais qui ne sont
assises bien sûr sur aucune demande
réelle c'est ce que nous appelons la
fraude et par ailleurs il y a des
situations d'escroquerie c'est-à-dire là
des entreprises qui peuvent conduire à
un moment donné des ménages vers des
demandes de subvention plus élevées que
les dispositifs ou les équipements qui
vont être posés à l'intérieur des
logements et ces deux pratiques ne sont
pas exactement les mêmes sur ces deux
pratiques Lana depuis que Lana existe
Lana verse donc des subventions
extrêmement importantes à l'ensemble des
usagers qu'il a sollicitent et lutte
contre la fraude à travers un plan et
qui de contrôle et de maîtrise des
risques de l'agence sur l'ensemble de
nos aides et donc ce dispositif que nous
appliquons depuis de nombreuses années
nous l'avons bien entendu déployer pour
ma prime rénov donc c'est important que
que vous l'ayez en tête ça sous-entend
du contrôle sur pièce
mathématiques sur l'ensemble des
dossiers qui sont déposés auprès de
l'agence et du contrôle sur place
c'est-à-dire pour vérifier la mise en
oeuvre des travaux sur 10% des dossiers
qui nous sont qui nous sont évidemment
demandés pour subventions et ce avant le
versement de la subvention en question
donc ça c'est vraiment le l'axe
évidemment central pour l'opérateur qui
est Lana c'est cette lutte contre la
fraude et nous sommes amenés parfois
soit dans enfin dans certains cas à
augmenter j'y reviendrai nos contrôles
c'est à dire à
opérer des contrôles renforcés sur un
certain nombre de dossiers lorsque
notamment nous observons au travers de
ces contrôles sur pièces ou de ces et de
ses contrôles sur place que il peut y
avoir il y a dérives en fait par rapport
à la simple demande de subvention pour
pouvoir réaliser des travaux chez des
gens qui souhaitent améliorer leur
logement deuxième axe de nos actions
nous participons évidemment au groupe de
travail que Simon Yvetot a dû
évoquer lors de son audition
c'est-à-dire autour de la mission de
coordination interministérielle qui
permet de mettre en commun en fait
autour de différents ministères ce que
nous observons et nos pratiques et aussi
nos signalements et puis nous faisons
aussi troisième axe de notre action de
la sensibilisation vis-à-vis des ménages
à travers différentes campagnes de
communication campagne de communication
que nous relayons très régulièrement et
qui
je le partage avec vous parce que c'est
très important rappelez que une
structure comme Lana un établissement
public administratif de l'État un
opérateur comme Lana ne fait jamais de
démarchage toutes toutes démarchage sous
le nom de Lana ne peut pas exister et
forcément signal de fraude et
deuxièmement un deuxième axe très
important de notre information et notre
communication vis-à-vis des usagers
leur rappeler qu'il n'y a jamais besoin
de se précipiter en fait pour pouvoir
signer un devis ou pour pouvoir signer
tout autre offre commerciale quelle
qu'elle soit qu'elle soit d'ailleurs de
nature bancaire ou qu'elle soit de
nature de en matière de réalisation de
travaux de façon et qu'il est nécessaire
en fait de prendre le temps et qu'il est
nécessaire aussi de réfléchir avant que
de s'engager dans une démarche de
travaux dans la mesure où ces travaux
portent sur un patrimoine qui appartient
à ces ménages et puis nous avons été
amenés dans ce contexte évidemment je le
précisais tout à l'heure à renforcer nos
contrôles notamment depuis l'été 2022
parce que nous avons justement
pointé en fait un certain nombre de
situations de fraude et d'escroquerie
sur un certain nombre d'équipements ce
qui nous a amené à contrôler beaucoup
plus systématiquement à la fois en
contrôle sur place ce type de
réalisation de travaux et aussi à
contrôler l'identité des demandeurs pour
s'assurer qu'il bien un demandeur
derrière la demande ce qui a provoqué
d'ailleurs un certain nombre de délais
rallongés dans les délais de paiement de
l'agence et que sur lesquels nous avons
été amenés d'ailleurs à communiquer à la
fois au mois de l'automne dernier puis
en fin d'année 2022 et plus récemment en
lien notamment avec les deux
organisations professionnelles que sont
la CAPEB et la FFB qui nous avait
d'ailleurs sollicité sur ces délais de
paiement qui étaient rallongés voilà les
éléments importants que que nous
souhaitions partager avec vous au sujet
de ces questions de fraude sur
sur les
sur la quatrième question excusez-moi
relative donc aux politiques de
rénovation énergétique et notamment ce
que
Emmanuel wargon a déclaré à savoir que
le nombre d'artisans qualifiés stagne
n'a plus ou moins 10 ou 15 % de son
niveau potentiel vous nous demandez si
nous partageons cette analyse alors il
est difficile pour l'agence de partager
cette analyse ce dont nous sommes
convaincus c'est ce que le président de
Lana pointait dans son introduction
c'est que la rénovation énergétique et
l'affaire de tous donc il peut y avoir
il faut une aide de l'état de qualité il
faut d'autres aides pour réduire le
reste à charge il faut un réseau
bancaire qui soit en capacité de pouvoir
évidemment combler ce reste à charge et
permettre à tous les ménages quel que
soit leur niveau de ressources de
pouvoir accéder à des prêts et il faut
des entreprises de qualité ce que la
CAPEB et la FFB nous disent c'est une
situation plutôt de confiance de leur
part par rapport à l'ensemble de leurs
réseaux
et notamment par rapport au réseau qui
bénéficie d'un label RGE mais je pense
que ce point mérite d'être d'être
approfondi avec ces deux ces deux
fédérations qui bien entendu sont plus
sont plus à même de pouvoir partager
avec vous des données chiffrées ce qui
est certain c'est que sur l'ensemble des
territoires aujourd'hui nous constatons
que nous nous inscrivons dans les
tendances des deux années précédentes en
matière de dépôt de dossier donc que
l'on est bien sur une capacité des
entreprises aujourd'hui à pouvoir
répondre en tout cas à des volumes
budgétaires qui annoncent dès le début
de l'année un volume de rénovation
énergétique pour l'année en revanche
l'appareil économique que j'ai envie de
dire pour pouvoir peut-être aller plus
loin mériterait d'être examiné beaucoup
plus de façon beaucoup plus approfondie
mais je peux partager avec vous que dans
nos échanges avec la CAPEB et la FFB ils
nous ont aussi parlé des formations en
cours en matière d'apprentissage et
aussi dans les lycées professionnel
enfin ils ont de la donnée enfin pardon
de le formuler comme ça mais je pense
que ils sont beaucoup plus à même de
partager ces données en profondeur avec
vous donc voilà pour la réponse à la
question 4 sur la question numéro 5 vous
nous interrogez sur les moyens et
prestations de conseils de que auquel
l'agence a recours et notamment durant
son audition en tant qu'enseigne
ministre sur la question 5 Emmanuel
cosse aurait déclaré que la NA n'a pas
la capacité d'engager des fonds sur
plusieurs années comme par exemple
l'Agence nationale pour la rénovation
urbaine
et vous nous demandez si nous partageons
cette analyse sur les propositions à ce
sujet il conviendra rappeler que donc
Lana est financée dont par le budget de
l'État et que effectivement c'est un
financement annuel qui repose sur le
vote de la loi de finances initiale et
qui repose bien sûr aussi sur le vote du
budget initial de l'agence qui a lieu
chaque année en conseil d'administration
en fin d'année pour l'année suivante
la réponse à la question que vous
soulevez et premièrement que le budget
de l'ANAH a été multiplié par plus de 5
sur les années que nous examinons autour
de vous donc l'État a mis les moyens sur
les années qui viennent de s'écouler
pour mettre en adéquation les budgets de
cette agence avec la mise en place des
politiques locales de l'habitat par les
collectivités territoriales et répondre
aussi à la demande en fait très forte de
subventions pour pouvoir améliorer les
logements le président de Lana précisait
tout à l'heure que aujourd'hui le budget
de l'agence s'élève à 4 milliards
d'euros par an et ce budget si on le
cynde en deux grandes parties 2 milliard
5 relèvent de ma prime rénov par gestes
comme on dit c'est-à-dire voilà cette
aide qui sert essentiellement dans la
rénovation énergétique et un milliard 5
pour l'année 2023 et dédié
aux aides à la pierre ce qui correspond
à plus du doublement en fait sur la
période que nous examinons en matière
d'aide à la pierre donc à destination
des collectivités territoriales et des
territoires qui sont concernés par
ailleurs je le disais tout à l'heure le
nombre d'opérations programmées
d'amélioration de l'habitat et de
programme d'intérêt généraux donc
contractualisé entre Lana et les
collectivités territoriales ne fait
qu'augmenter sur la même période et ce
sont des engagements que Lana et l'État
prennent avec les collectivités
territoriales sur du pluriel donc sur
trois ans voir 5 ans dans certains cas
avec un engagement évidemment de montant
d'aide à la fois en subvention donc en
aide aux travaux et en même temps en
ingénierie puisque la nafinance aussi
les collectivités territoriales en
ingénierie et donc engagement sur
plusieurs années pour pouvoir réaliser
bien entendu les programmes en question
sur l'ensemble des territoires qui sont
concernés et qui le demandent
à la question numéro 6 au travers de la
question numéro 6 vous nous interrogez
sur les moyens qui sont qui sont dévolus
à l'agence à la fois en termes
budgétaire et en ressources humaines
donc en ETP pour accomplir les missions
qui nous sont confiées donc ainsi que je
vous le disais précédemment donc l'état
renouvelle chaque année depuis
maintenant 2019 sa confiance à cette
agence sous forme budgétaire en
augmentant notamment son budget par plus
de 5 au travers donc de ces aides à ma
prime rénove et des aides à la pierre et
les et l'État
renouvelle aussi sa confiance en nous
donnant les moyens de fonctionnement et
les moyens d'investissement aussi pour
nous permettre de répondre à ces enjeux
et donc le les évolutions notamment en
matière d'effectif sont indiqués en loi
de finance initiale chaque année et nous
avons nous aujourd'hui enfin depuis
cette depuis cette date de 2019 nous
augmentons nos objectifs de plus de 30
TP chaque année ce qui fait que l'agence
est passé d'un effectif d'une centaine
de collaborateurs en 2018 à plus de 200
collaborateurs et même 250
collaborateurs à la fin de l'année 2023
ce qui est tout à fait considérable et
après autre élément important par
rapport à ces moyens je crois que on ne
peut pas se limiter dans la mesure où
c'est une politique de l'habitat donc
une politique de territoire on ne peut
pas se limiter à regarder les moyens
uniquement de l'agence mais il est aussi
important et là-dessus l'agence ne sera
pas enfin ne sera pas en mesure de
donner des éléments d'appréciation mais
en revanche il est important de regarder
aussi les moyens qui sont dévolus en
collectivité territoriale et aussi dans
les services déconcentrés de l'État
puisque une grande partie en tout cas un
milliard 5 du budget de l'agence repose
bien entendu sur ses crédits délégués
dans les territoires
en délégation d'aide à la pierre ou au
sein des services de l'État pour faire
en sorte que ces aides soient bien
distribuées selon les demandes des
usagers qui les sollicitent
sur le rôle des cabinets de conseils et
en particulier de Capgemini qui font
l'objet de votre question numéro 7 dans
le déploiement et la mise en oeuvre de
ma prime rénov vous nous demandez donc
vous nous posez un certain nombre de
questions sur les missions qui ont été
externalisées donc il est important
d'être précis sur ces éléments dans la
mesure où ces prestations
réalisées sont de nature
différente on va dire donc tout à fait
de façon tout à fait claire nous avons
sollicité Capgemini pour accompagner
l'agence dans la mise en place donc d'un
nouveau système de d'information
à partir de 2020 et un nouveau système
d'instruction parce que la plateforme ma
prime rénov dans ton parle beaucoup et
parfois souvent est une plateforme qui a
ce qu'on appelle dans notre jargon un
front office c'est-à-dire celui que vous
connaissez celui où on dépose une
demande et puis il y a un back office
c'est celui ou sur lequel nous
instruisons donc demande et c'est dans
ce contexte là que nous avons sollicité
donc ces prestations je le rappelle
aussi 25
000 décisions sont prises par semaine
autour de ma prime rénove je crois qu'il
est important de de le partager avec
vous 50% de ses décisions relèvent de
l'engagement c'est-à-dire des prises de
décision qui octroient une subvention à
des usagers qui l'ont sollicité et 50
autres % concernent des paiements donc
de subventions après réalisation de
travaux donc voilà le volume sont tout à
fait conséquents et c'est pour cette
raison que nous avons donc fait appel à
ces prestations pour développer à la
fois ce système d'information et
évidemment construire l'ensemble de la
plateforme et l'ensemble des process
l'ensemble des process qui sont attachés
à un dépôt de demande de dossier ou
évidemment une instruction de ce dossier
à l'engagement ou au paiement il est
intervenu alors élément important à
partager c'est que Capgemini est bien
entendu intervenu dans le cadre de
marchés publics marchés publics de
l'État
notamment porté par la D i TP et c'est
au travers de ces marchés publics que
nous avons pu faire appel à ces assez
prestations et l'objectif c'est bien sûr
un appui et un appui pardon à la
définition de cette feuille de route
pour pouvoir créer l'ensemble des
dispositifs que je citais précédemment
et qui nous ont permis de déployer ma
prime rénove mais qui nous ont aussi
permis à partir ce qu'on a déployé ma
prime rénov comme je vous le disais tout
à l'heure en 2020 pour déménage modestes
et très modestes et ensuite nous avons
énormément élargi évidemment le la
capacité de cette plateforme et notre
capacité d'instruction puisque ma prime
rénov a été ouverte à l'ensemble des
propriétaires ou potentiellement
bénéficiaire de ces aides et puis
évidemment au travers de ces prestations
nous avons mis en place aussi l'ensemble
des chantiers qui ont permis de mettre
en place cette instruction mais aussi
tous les dispositifs de de translation
j'ai envie de dire par exemple sur
l'afro des sur la lutte contre
l'escroquerie au dispositif ma prime
rénov tel que nous l'avions mis en place
dans le cadre de nos aides à la pierre
préalablement et puis nous avons mis en
place aussi une relation
usagée je partage aussi avec vous un
chiffre qui est toujours impressionnant
nous recevons 8000 appels jours sur la
plateforme téléphonique de Lana qui
enregistre un taux de décroché de 85% et
parfois même de 90% enfin en tout cas
qui varient maintenant invariablement
d'ailleurs entre 85 et 90% de taux de
décroché chaque semaine depuis
maintenant deux ans même s'il a pu
connaître évidemment au tout début de la
mise en œuvre des moments un peu plus
difficiles et puis bien entendu nous
avons toute la soutenabilité de cette
plateforme
inutile de vous dire que nous nous
connaissons de temps en temps des
difficultés puisque on y reviendra tout
à l'heure par exemple sur les questions
fiscales mais nous sommes apaisés comme
on dit c'est à dire que nous avons des
bien en fait entre URL entre cette
plateforme et puis par exemple l'ADEM
pour vérifier évidemment que les
entreprises sont RGE ou avec la DGFiP
pour évidemment vérifier les
identifiants fiscaux et les identités
tout court des demandeurs donc nous
avons parfois des difficultés de
fonctionnement de cette plateforme qui
peuvent être liées toute façon à des
mises j'ai envie de dire à des mises des
mises à niveau ou des ajustements en
fait des différentes plateformes par
exemple avec lesquelles nous sont liés
ou notre propre plateforme qui
qui
excusez-moi qui peut aussi à certains
moments avoir besoin d'être ajusté
donc c'est un apport d'expertise sur des
domaines tout à fait spécifiques et
ceux-ci dans un dans un contexte
évidemment de demande très très forte et
d'objectif de résultats auxquels
l'agence a su répondre il n'y a jamais
eu je le précise aussi lors de cette
commission d'interruption de services
sur ma prime rénov donc c'est un travail
extrêmement important que nous que nous
opérons avec ce prestataire pour assurer
la tenue de ce service public tout au
long de l'année et ce 365 jours sur 365
en question 8
vous allez vous dire
oui parce que j'ai enchaîné
j'ai enchaîné mais peut-être que
effectivement je n'aurais pas dû et je
vous prie de m'excuser vous me
donc sur vous nous interrogez sur les
sommes dépensées chaque année pour les
prestations de conseil alors je souhaite
partager avec vous cet après-midi que la
commission d'enquête sénatoriale sur le
rôle des cabinets de conseil il y a
exactement un an nous avait interrogé
sur ces points que l'ensemble des
données ont été transmises à cette
commission d'enquête que certaines de
ces données ont un caractère
confidentiel mais que en revanche nous
sommes à votre disposition pour
évidemment élargir et répondre plus
précisément à cette question en dehors
de l'audition de cet après-midi et enfin
sur la question numéro 9
sur qui pointent un article du Monde
effectivement du 2 juillet dernier un
témoignage d'un agent de Lana au sujet
de Capgemini qui disait ils sont là
depuis tellement d'années qu'on se
demande pourquoi ne pas avoir carrément
embauché des fonctionnaires qualifiés
pour assumer ses missions pérennes j'ai
envie de vous répondre que compte tenu
des descriptions de missions que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure qui sont
démission extrêmement techniques autour
des systèmes d'information de la très
forte tension aussi je le partage très
librement avec vous sur ces marchés en
matière sur ces compétences pardon en
matière d'informatique ces compétences
ne sont pas au sein de l'agence et
l'apport de ce prestataire est tout à
fait précieux dans les développements et
les investissements que nous réalisons
dans ce domaine voilà madame la
présidente monsieur le rapporteur je
vous prie de m'excuser d'avoir enchaîné
ces 9 questions mais je suis à votre
disposition pour y revenir si vous le
souhaitez combien vous êtes passionnés
et combien vous avez à coeur de de
montrer ce que fait la NA donc je laisse
la parole à notre rapporteur pour
maintenant vous poser des questions
supplémentaires
merci monsieur le Président et merci
Madame la Directrice Générale non mais
c'est très bien
[Rires]
non peut-être du coup en complément par
rapport à ce que vous avez déjà une
question sur le
vous avez vous avez dit à un moment
donné que du coup vous aviez vous avez
un certain nombre de contrôle par
rapport au fraude qui pouvait y avoir et
vous avez parlé de contrôle direct sur
sur site
donc ça je voulais avoir des précisions
sur quel type de contrôle et qu'est-ce
que vous vérifiez en fait quand vous
faites des contrôles sur site et là
peut-être la proportion en tout cas de
ces contrôles quoi est-ce que c'est
vraiment quelque chose de de très
particulier et qui reste très
anecdotique ou est-ce que c'est quelque
chose que vous avez l'habitude plutôt de
plutôt de réaliser
ensuite c'est vrai que vous avez répondu
déjà beaucoup de choses et avec et avec
précision non il y avait peut-être sur
le sur la question de de ce qui a été
abordé sur ma prime rénov et sur
l'aspect de la rénovation de la
rénovation globale c'est vrai que si on
regarde les chiffres et qu'il y avait
quel que soit les organismes ou voilà
qui ont pu on s'aperçoit quand même que
sur ma prime rénove si on peut
satisfaire du nombre de effectivement de
personnes qui ont qui ont bénéficié de
ma prime rénov on peut s'interroger un
peu plus sur sur justement le fait qu'on
ait des faibles taux sur la rénovation
globale alors c'est vrai que suivant les
différents interlocuteurs qu'on a pu
avoir et les différentes auditions
certains nous disent il faudrait aller
vraiment mettre tout sur la rénovation
globale et d'autres nous disent non la
rénovation par geste elle est importante
et ça permet justement de rentrer dans
un dans un processus à condition
justement que ça soit un processus enfin
je veux dire que du coup il y a eu
l'analyse il y a eu la réflexion sur
l'ensemble de la rénovation mais du coup
je voulais avoir un petit peu votre
votre retour par rapport à par rapport à
ça parce que ça pour le coup les
chiffres sur la rénovation globale reste
quand même très très faibles
et notamment sur le fait aussi et
peut-être la dérive qui pourrait y avoir
c'est que si on regarde les chiffres
aussi c'est que sur le nombre de primor
je sais pas exactement quel qu'est-ce
que ça représente mais on va dire sur le
changement de chaudière tout simple
c'est quelque chose quand même qui est
très important et notamment sur le
passage avec avec des packs des pompes à
chaleur
et c'est vrai que dans le débat qu'on a
pu avoir on pourrait avoir une réflexion
uniquement basée notamment sur le le
rejet carbone quoi et sur l'impact
carbone et de se dire ben si on remplace
l'ensemble de notre système de chauffage
par des électriques
on peut régler et par l'électrique donc
abonnés du coup on peut régler la
problématique la problématique carbone
et je dirais le tour est joué quoi
sauf que bon il me semble que ça serait
c'est fin c'est pas forcément la bonne
solution que ça pose bien d'autres
problèmes c'est que la question de la
rénovation thermique elle est à la fois
sur la en termes de en terme de confort
et puis que cette production électrique
il faut bien la produire donc on est
quand même sur essayer de réduire plutôt
cette consommation et donc le fait qu'on
ait développé plutôt des aides sur des
chaudières et notamment sur des pompes à
chaleur c'est sûr qu'on dimensionne du
coup on des pompes à chaleur sur des
bâtiments qui ne sont pas isolés et qui
normalement devrait l'être par la suite
et donc voilà on pose vraiment la
question sur le fait que est-ce qu'on
commence pas par quelque chose auquel
plutôt on devrait on devrait terminer
donc voilà je voudrais bien avoir votre
votre avis en tout cas et vos et vos
retours sur cette sur cet aspect là bon
sur la question de la fraude et des
difficultés face à pu révéler le
Défenseur des droits et peut-être c'est
vrai
quand même je trouve encore enfin pour
avoir pas vu pas mal de dossiers sur
souvent les difficultés qu'on peut avoir
pour avoir des informations et sur
l'explication des informations pour
lequel les personnes du coup ne peuvent
pas toucher leur prime ou en tout cas se
retrouvent face à des situations assez
assez complexes c'est vrai pour avoir
quelques
quelques dossiers en question je pense
qu'il y a encore améliorer en tout cas
sur sur cette et peut-être sur la
question aussi du droit à l'erreur enfin
moi ce que j'ai vu beaucoup c'est
comment on peut mettre en place en fait
le fait que des personnes souvent
et la plupart du temps de bonne foi qui
se sont trompés juste dans leur dossier
pour une histoire de date pour une
histoire de de remplissage du dossier et
qui se retrouvent en fait en bringué
dans quelque chose qui qui après les
dépasses et plus possible de revenir de
revenir en arrière et une dernière
question plus sur la question en lien
avec les avec les collectivités avec les
collectivités locales et notamment dans
le cas du service public de rénovation
de l'habitat du coup vous enfin voilà le
rôle de Nana et vous participez au
service public de la rénovation de
l'habitat et donc comment comment selon
vous du coup se passe cet articulation
avec les collectivités locales c'est
vrai qu'on a eu j'ai eu pas mal de
retour notamment plutôt de petites
collectivités d'intercaux qui avaient en
fait à une époque mais en place des des
plateformes de rénovation qui avait un
système assez simple et qui fonctionnait
plutôt pas mal et qui nous disent
aujourd'hui on y comprend plus rien quoi
et
[Musique]
que on est on a l'impression en fait de
tout refaire et de tout remettre en
place et avec des chiffres aussi que
j'ai vu c'est à dire que on avait des
des taux de rénovation qui étaient assez
importantes et qui là ce sont totalement
effondrés parce que justement on a perdu
un petit peu de en termes de lisibilité
donc je voulais avoir votre votre tour
par rapport à ça et puis peut-être au
retour que vous avez aussi de la part
des collectivités
merci
je les prends dans l'ordre donc sur les
contrôles sur place
donc comme je vous le disais nous vous
appliquons en fait un taux de 10% en
fait nous nous contrôlons à 100%
l'ensemble des dossiers mais surpasse
c'est-à-dire nous contrôlons l'identité
d'une demandeur pour faire court et le
devis qui nous est transmis quel que
soit l'aide et nous contrôlons sur place
donc 10% des dossiers au moment de la
demande de paiement autant sur les aides
à la pierre que sur ma prime c'est le
chiffre donc ça nous permet de vérifier
alors
on a des contrôles complètement
aléatoires je veux dire comme ça tirer
au sort voilà et on a aussi des
contrôles précis pas du tout aléatoires
au regard de certaines
certains contrôles sur pièces que nous
faisons dans nos services et qui nous
amènent sur un territoire donné
vis-à-vis de certains acteurs à dépêcher
en fait ce type de contrôle et qu'est-ce
que nous constatons globalement
plutôt beaucoup de satisfaction enfin
voilà 90% de ces contrôles sur place
révèlent en fait que le dossier peut
être payé
et 10% nous révèlent que le dossier ne
peut pas être payé tout simplement parce
que les alors on a toutes sortes de
situations des travaux qui n'ont pas été
réalisés
avec un ménage qui est en situation
parfois difficile ou des travaux qui ont
été réalisés de façon différente de ce
que le devis et la facture
prévoit c'est-à-dire un type
d'équipement en deçà du niveau voilà du
niveau signalé enfin c'est voilà une
qualité j'ai envie de dire de travaux
inférieurs en fait à ce qui est facturé
dans la facture qui nous est soumise au
paiement alors dans ces cas là la
situation est très simple c'est que nous
bloquons le paiement et
la personne qui enfin le premier la
personne qui subit en fait le plus ce
type de situation bien évidemment c'est
le ménage et nous allons dans ce cas
dans ce contexte là faire en sorte de
lui permettre de retrouver un parcours
un parcours qui lui permet d'aller
jusqu'au bout de ses travaux et de
pouvoir bénéficier de la subvention
pleinement et entièrement quel que soit
d'ailleurs le montant de travaux que ce
soit des travaux modestes que ce soit
des travaux importants l'objectif est
toujours le même c'est celui de
permettre à un ménage de se remettre
dans un parcours le plus favorable
possible pour lui et son patrimoine
juste une précision les types de
contrôle c'est du contrôle visuel
contrôle sur place c'est du contrôle sur
place dans le logement
thermique
de ce qui a été réalisé si c'est
l'isolation en extérieur mais il y a pas
de pas de contrôle sur la qualité des
travaux
si c'est un bureau de enfin ce sont les
agents des services déconcentrés ou des
collectivités territoriales pour ce qui
relève des aides à la pierre et pour ce
qui relève de ma prime rénov c'est un
marché qui est passé avec le bureau de
contrôle Veritas et c'est une
vérification que le
l'équipement qui est signalé et bien le
bon et que si par exemple c'est une
isolation par l'extérieur en produits
biosourcés c'est du produit biosourcés
peut-être dire pour faire souffler cinq
minutes Madame la Directrice Générale
qui en a besoin que ces contrôles c'est
aussi
pour les personnes
la certitude que les travaux ont été
réalisés comme l'ont dit dans les règles
de l'art et qu'on se doit effectivement
de vérifier si les choses ont été bien
faites avec aussi parfois
c'est un de nos soucis des difficultés à
ce que les ménages eux-mêmes acceptent
d'ouvrir la porte pour vérifier que les
travaux ont été bien faits parce que
souvent quand elles ont ces ménages
comme interlocuteur une entreprise
mandataire elle ne connaissent pas
forcément Lana et encore moins le
cabinet que nous avons spécialisé pour
aller vérifier le bon rendu des travaux
et tant que nous avons pas pu rentrer
pour vérifier il y a une suspicion que
les travaux ne soient parfois pas
réalisés il faut se dire les choses ou
mal réaliser ce qui du coup peut prendre
quelques jours
voire plus quand vraiment on est
personne qui répond quoi alors on
sensibilise d'ailleurs une réunion est
pas très longtemps avec la FFB et la
CAPEB pour que les entreprises des
mandataire explique que c'est tout à
fait normal que quelqu'un qui un jour se
présente dans de Lana Vienne vérifier
les travaux je dis ça parce que ça
explique parfois aussi du retard il y a
beaucoup beaucoup de cas particuliers
maintenant je profite du coup sur ce
sujet là parce qu'on a eu dans les
différentes auditions pas mal de
réflexion sur justement l'aspect du
contrôle quoi en fait et de la bonne
réalisation des travaux et parfois de se
positionner qu'on est plutôt
actuellement dans un système où on a
labellisé des entreprises donc on se dit
elles sont RGE donc elles sont en
capacité de faire des de réaliser des
travaux correctement et donc du coup on
n'a pas de contrôle systématique en fin
de chantier quoi et on pourrait poser
cette question inverse quoi et de se
dire en fait peu importe je dirais
labellisation de l'entreprise à
condition que le résultat soit soit
correct et donc d'avoir plutôt un
contrôle en fin de chantier ce qui se
fait par exemple soit assainissement ou
des choses comme ça ou du coup c'est
c'est clairement un contrôle qui valide
ensuite la subvention est-ce que ça vous
paraît crédible en fait par rapport à
votre expérience et à ce que ce que ce
qui est déjà mis en place si vous dites
que vous faites 10% déjà
des des contrôles
ce que vous pointez et qui est aussi
relevé par le président de la NAS et la
question de la confiance en fait des
ménages dans la réalisation des travaux
qui sont exécutés dans leur logement
une des réponses en fait à cette
question c'est mon accompagnateur Renov
c'est en fait l'accompagnement enfin les
aident à la pierre pour le dire de façon
différente dans les aides à la pierre
l'accompagnement est obligatoire depuis
toujours donc sur ma prime rénov
sérénité ma prime rénov copropriété nous
aide à l'autonomie les aident en
traitement de l'habitat indigne
l'ensemble des aides de l'agence
l'accompagnement est obligatoire pour ma
prime rénov il est optionnel avec un
forfait il est peu utilisé et en fait
par le vote de la loi climat résilience
et le décret qui est paru en fin d'année
dernière cette obligation m'annonce va
s'étendre à toutes les opérations un peu
ambitieuses et c'est et c'est le tiers
de confiance
indispensable pour permettre
effectivement de s'assurer que les
travaux sont réalisés
de façon conforme à la à la prescription
qui a été faite initialement et au devis
qui a été présenté au ménage
sur les autres questions sur la question
de la rénovation globale
c'est un vaste sujet
alors je commence avec les chiffres
parce que c'est ce qu'il y a de plus
facile en fait au fond et nous avions eu
l'occasion de le pointer aussi devant la
commission des affaires économiques il y
a un chiffre de 2200 dossiers par an qui
a été pointé notamment par un excellent
rapport de la Cour des comptes mais qui
ne regardait que ma prime rénov
nationale c'est-à-dire l'aide versée au
niveau national et qui ne regardait donc
que les forfaits rénovation globales
sollicité par les ménages de catégories
intermédiaires et supérieures et ne
regardez pas ni ma prime rénov sérénité
ni ma prime rénov copropriété donc le
vrai chiffre c'est celui que j'évoquais
tout ailleurs depuis trois ans 176 000
dossiers traités donc depuis trois ans
depuis 2011 plus de 500 000 dossiers
plus de 600 000 dossiers pardon et donc
10% par qui
ménage donc qui réalise des travaux de
rénovation globale
pour pouvoir bénéficier de ces
subventions ces ménages doivent réaliser
un seau un gain énergétique de 35 % et
la moyenne que nous constatons au
travers de nos études c'est qu'ils font
un gain énergétique de l'ordre de 50%
. donc c'est c'est important et en tout
cas ça révèle bien que cette rénovation
globale que le président de Lana
pointait comme étant évidemment le
parcours idéal en une fois une seule est
effectivement la démarche que l'on
pourrait souhaiter pour l'ensemble des
ménages du parc privé pour autant
ce n'est pas toujours possible pour des
raisons diverses des raisons de coûts de
mon temps de travaux le reste à charge
qui existe autour de la rénovation
globale est une réalité et dans les
rénovations globales c'est bien la
question de l'aide de l'État et de la
complémentarité de l'aide des
collectivités territoriales qui fait la
différence sur le reste à charge
auquel on peut rajouter des certificats
d'économie d'énergie mais effectivement
c'est un point extrêmement important et
ensuite on a aussi des ménages qui ne le
souhaitent pas je crois que enfin le
il est important de partager que et on
le partage d'ailleurs très librement au
sein du réseau France rénov tout le
monde souhaiterait pouvoir recevoir un
ménage en espace conseil France rénov ou
dans une maison de l'habitat attachée à
une opération programmée d'amélioration
de l'habitat et voir ressortir ce ménage
avec l'envie de réaliser une rénovation
globale dans son logement et c'est à
dire plusieurs semaines voire mois de
travaux mais tous les ménages ne vont
pas avoir envie de le faire d'une seule
fois d'une seule et certains vont
s'engager dans une démarche par étape et
il est important dont la politique
publique d'avoir les deux parcours qui
soient proposés
alors en ce qui concerne cette
rénovation globale il y a donc
effectivement l'aide financière qui est
apportée aux ménage et pas simplement
l'aile de l'État je le redis les
certificats d'économie d'énergie et les
aides des collectivités territoriales
l'appétence évidemment du ménage à le
faire l'accompagnement qui va être
auprès des ménages pour leur permettre
de s'engager en toute conscience dans la
démarche et ensuite un réseau
d'entreprises de qualité et de confiance
qui va pouvoir réaliser ses travaux
la différence en matière de rénovation
globale c'est qu'on a un éparpillement
très fort de l'artisanat en matière de
bâtiment dans notre pays et très peu
d'entreprises générales à disposition
des particuliers des petits particuliers
pour pouvoir réaliser une rénovation
globale et donc l'accompagnement est une
première réponse est une réponse bien
sûr pour permettre une meilleure
coordination je vais le dire entre un
maçon un menuisier et un plombier
chauffagiste mais ce n'est peut-être pas
suffisant et on a aussi besoin d'avoir
de la coordination qui s'organise entre
ces corps d'état au niveau des
entreprises pour pouvoir permettre
réellement de démultiplier la rénovation
globale et d'avoir une offre efficace en
temps j'ai envie de dire surtout en
temps c'est pas tant en qualité mais en
temps pour permettre à ces travaux de se
réaliser le plus sereinement possible à
l'intérieur d'un ménage qui je le
rappelle à l'intérieur d'un logement
pardon qui je le rappelle est occupé par
une famille au moment où les travaux se
réalise donc cette qualité est
extrêmement importante ensuite sur les
deux parcours possibles on a bien deux
objectifs au travers de cette politique
publique une politique publique vous
l'avez très bien
rappelé monsieur le rapporteur le
politique publique qui consiste à
décarboner donc effectivement
aujourd'hui on a on a 60% des aides de
ma prime rénov en 2022 qui ont concerné
un changement de chauffage et 20% qui
ont concerné
l'isolation
ce qui est une progression par rapport
aux demandes en matière d'isolation mais
encore insuffisante et le la sortie de
d'énergie d'énergie fossile est un point
très important dans un monde idéal il
faudrait pouvoir avoir des écosystèmes
des réseaux en fait organisés au niveau
territorial qui se renvoient en fait les
ménages si je peux me permettre de le
dire ainsi pour bien le conseiller pour
le pour le dire très concrètement un
espace conseil France donne une
information un conseil et souhaite
orienter un ménage vers la rénovation la
plus performante pour lui et pour son
logement
un artisan qui reçoit une demande en
direct et qui voit que cette demande
n'est risque de ne pas être performante
pour le logement devrait pouvoir
renvoyer vers un espace conseil France
Renov pour plus d'informations et plus
de conseils et c'est ce vers quoi nous
souhaitons tendre de plus en plus au
travers du réseau France rénov
c'est-à-dire c'est pas simplement
installer des espaces conseils ou des
maisons de l'habitat des équipes de
suivi animation sur le territoire c'est
aussi créer des liens en fait entre les
différents réseaux d'acteurs parce que
réussir une rénovation globale dans le
parc privé face à des maîtres d'ouvrage
qui le sont pour une période très courte
et qui ne sont pas des maîtres
d'ouvrages professionnels c'est
s'assurer que les professionnels
correspondent entre eux et
convergent collectivement pour mettre le
ménage dans le meilleur parcours
possible
sur la question relative à la Défenseur
des droits
plusieurs plusieurs choses à partager
avec vous
sur lesquels nous pourrons revenir par
écrit si vous le souhaitez mais
premièrement peut-être la première chose
c'est la Défenseur des droits
effectivement souligner un certain
nombre d'usagers qui étaient en
situation difficile je rappelle les
chiffres c'était c'est important
500 dossiers étaient signalés donc par
la Défenseur des droits auprès de
l'agence et au moment où la Défenseur
des droits a pris sa
fait pas en fait de ça de sa décision
publiquement plus de la moitié de ces
dossiers enfin la moitié de ces dossiers
étaient déjà résolu et nous étions déjà
en contact avec la Défenseur des droits
puisque nous sommes aussi en contact
avec un certain nombre de ces délégués
sur l'ensemble du territoire et
résolvons les dossiers au fur et à
mesure donc la moitié de ces était déjà
résolu et c'est important qu'il
c'est important de enfin voilà c'est
important d'avoir ces chiffres en tête
par rapport donc 500 dossiers par
rapport au 25000 décisions par semaine
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure je pense
que c'est ses proportions restent
importantes à avoir en tête ensuite pour
autant 500 dossiers en difficulté c'est
toujours 500 dossier de trop donc
lorsque nous avons pris conscience en
fait de de ces difficultés c'est ce que
le président de Lana précisait tout à
l'heure nous avons mis en place une
équipe dédiée une équipe dédiée donc à
partir du moment où nous avons un
signalement nous prenons en charge en
fait le ménage en question et nous le
remettons dans un parcours normalisé
parfois c'est compliqué parfois c'est
compliqué pour diverses raisons parce
qu'il peut y avoir un blocage
informatique mais aussi parce qu'il peut
y avoir une incompréhension de la pièce
que nous attendons dans le cadre d'un
contrôle renforcé par exemple une visite
sur c'est un contrôle d'identité qui qui
n'est pas particulièrement qui n'est pas
qui particulièrement facile et par
rapport aux demandes de la Défenseur des
droits ce qui est important de de
partager avec vous c'est que nous avons
mis en place plusieurs choses qu'elle
demandait et qui était déjà en cours de
de réalisation d'abord la possibilité de
mettre en place un dossier de
régularisation c'est-à-dire lorsqu'un
dossier au fond est en grande difficulté
je vais dire comme ça il faut pouvoir
traiter un dossier de régularisation et
ça c'est en place depuis l'automne 2021
la mise en place aussi de France Connect
pour sécuriser l'accès aux comptes la
création d'une fonctionnalité qui permet
d'annuler une demande
et la création d'une fonctionnalité pour
demander une prorogation de dossier en
sachant que elle était indispensable
mais aussi les délais de prorogation des
dossiers de ma prise rénov sont passés
de un an à deux ans ce qui a aussi
permis évidemment au ménage de pouvoir
s'inscrire dans des délais plus longs
pour pouvoir demander leurs paiement
donc l'ensemble de ces observations en
tout cas ont été prises en compte et
aujourd'hui sont des fonctionnalités qui
sont pleinement accessibles par
l'ensemble des ménages qui sont dans ces
situations soit en direct soit par
l'intermédiaire de l'équipe dédiée qui a
été mise en place directement dans les
services de l'agence pour les
accompagner
sur la question de la DG FIP tout à fait
ah oui sur les avis de dégrèvement il
était effectivement pas pris en compte
dans le cadre de nos liens avec la avec
la les fonctionnalités que la DGFiP met
à notre disposition donc pour vérifier
l'identité fiscale du demandeur
et donc et donc nous nous sommes
rapprochés de la DGFiP et donc depuis le
1er janvier dernier la DGFiP a aussi
fait évoluer son offre et désormais met
en place à notre attention et à
l'attention d'autres services d'ailleurs
de l'État une nouvelle API impôt
particulier qui intègre les avis de
dégrèvement ce qui évidemment nous
simplifie fortement la tâche et mais au
travers de cet API impôt particulier
aujourd'hui automatiquement les avis de
dégrèvement sont pris en compte et pour
ceux qui étaient en attente ils sont
désormais en voie de régularisation si
ce n'est déjà régular isé
pire aussi les questions à nos collègues
s'ils en ont
sur le sur le service public France
rénov donc il est mis en place depuis le
1er janvier 2022
il est le regroupement des espaces
conseils France rénov qui était avant
des espaces conseils faire et des
équipes de suivi animation des opas et
des programmes d'intérêt généraux donc
une quantité de personnes assez
importante sur l'ensemble du territoire
national qui permet sur maintenant
98% du territoire d'avoir un espace
conseil et un lieu d'information conseil
pour tous les ménages parfois c'est
enfin je dirais que dans les secteurs
les plus urbanisés on a ces espaces et
dans les secteurs plus ruraux on a des
espaces déambulants donc qui sont voilà
qui se déplacent souvent sur les
journées de marché donc on a des formes
différentes et qui sont adaptées en fait
aux spécificités royale Lana anime
effectivement ce réseau ce service
public depuis le 1er janvier 2022 c'est
important c'est important parce que
c'était des cultures différentes une
culture très rénovation énergétique d'un
côté une culture très amélioration de
l'habitat de l'autre et en fait ce que
nous cherchons au travers de ce
rapprochement des réseaux c'est que
l'ensemble des conseillers qui sont sur
le terrain et l'ensemble des
accompagnateurs d'aujourd'hui et de
demain soit bien dans la double logique
c'est-à-dire qu'on soit bien dans cette
logique de décarbonation qui peut être
un premier geste une première étape dans
un parcours de rénovation énergétique
sans jamais perdre de vue que
l'amélioration de l'habitat est
évidemment l'objectif
principal et essentiel à atteindre à
terme donc c'est quelque chose de
extrêmement important les collectivités
territoriales je vous le disais sont
très engagés dans ces démarches
puisqu'on est passé de 2000 d'un peu
moins de 1000 même conseillers France
rénov en 2019 à plus de 2200 aujourd'hui
et on est passé de 700 OPA et programmes
d'intérêt généraux à plus à 955 arrêt
des compteurs en fin d'année 2022 donc
on a ce que je vous disais en
introduction on ne voit sur les les
trois années qui viennent de s'écouler
qu'une augmentation très forte en fait
au fond d'engagement des collectivités
territoriales sur le sur le sur les
politiques de l'habitat sur les
politiques de l'habitat privé sur la
complexification je ne pense pas que ce
soit que la complexification vienne de
la plateforme France Renov qui est une
qui est plutôt une plateforme qui a tant
enfin qui a tendu et qui a rassemblé
l'ensemble justement des services qui
pouvaient exister en revanche il y a une
évolution des aides et on a nous aussi
entendu sur le terrain enfin moi j'ai
fait un tour de France l'an dernier je
suis allé dans toutes les régions à la
rencontre des espaces conseils France
rénov à la rencontre des collectivités
concernées c'est-à-dire des régions
jusqu'aux communes en passant par les
départements et les intercommunalités
pour entendre leur réactions par rapport
à la mise en place de ce service public
souvent ils nous disent que les aides
évoluent et évoluent régulièrement mais
comme je vous le disais tout à l'heure
on est aussi dans tout un travail de
convergence et d'évolution de ces aides
qui chaque année essaye en fait d'être
de coller de plus en plus aux attentes
des des citoyens et des ménages qui
souhaitent s'engager dans ces démarches
de travaux donc je pense que la
complexification vient de se plutôt de
ces éléments et enfin sur un
effondrement ou une chute en tout cas
nous dans nos données nationales on ne
voit qu'une progression chaque année des
demandes d'aide pas d'effondrement pas
de chute ni évidemment sur ma prime
rénov nationale ni sur ma prime rénov
sérénité ni sur ma prime rénov
copropriété qui ne fait que monter en
puissance depuis qu'on est sorti donc de
la période de crise sanitaire et de
l'empêchement des assemblées générales
euh mais en revanche une très grande
attention de notre part en ce moment sur
les effets de l'inflation c'est-à-dire
un renchérissement des coûts travaux qui
est une vraie réalité donc qui pourrait
nous amener à un moment donné à
peut-être constaté effectivement moins
de dépôts de demandes d'aide en tout cas
ce sera le premier indicateur pour
l'agence et évidemment à discuter avec
nos tutelles d'une évolution des
montants de travaux et des pourcentages
d'aide qui est vraiment un point
important et au-delà de l'inflation
Laurent chérissement des coûts d'une
manière générale et donc peut-être à
vérifier très fortement avec nos
opérateurs en tout cas
des hésitations ou en tout cas des
questionnements plus profonds des
ménages avant de s'engager dans une
démarche de travaux puisque ce sont des
investissements importants
ajouter un petit mot à ce que vient de
dire madame a dit à très général
monsieur le rapporteur sur le réseau
France rénov je crois que si on prend
l'analyse de nos concitoyens la mise en
place de France Renov ça a quand même
permis de faire comprendre effectivement
qu'il y avait un service public qui se
mettait en place avant il y avait des
coexistances de différents réseaux il y
avait ceux de l'ADEME il y avait celui
de Lana tout cela a fusionner dans une
entité qui aujourd'hui est France Renov
qui est présent effectivement dans 90
18% du territoire national je crois
qu'on en ouvre une là en Bretagne la
première semaine du mois de avril et en
fait ça a été accompagné par un plan de
communication quand même substantiel là
des heures de grande écoute y compris
télévisés dans la PQR par des pages
complètes et c'est sans doute ce succès
64% après un an de présence de France
rénov 64% des Français
savent comprennent ce que veut dire
France rénale accoler à un produit qui
s'appelle ma prime rénov et tout le
monde fait en fait l'amalgame avec un
produit alors même qu'on a tenté de vous
dire cet après-midi qu'il y en avait
plusieurs ma prime sérénité m'a pris mon
cas les Français ont quand même bien
capté à la fois le service public et le
produit ce qui fait que
c'est quand même assez je trouve
remarquable que sur une année de France
il y a eu 6 millions 800
000 de nos compatriotes qui se sont
connectés sur la plateforme et comme ça
a été dit 35000 appels sur la plateforme
aussi chaque semaine c'est assez
considérable en fait je crois qu'il
manquait une entité visuelle quelque
chose que les gens comprennent
spontanément c'est c'était un pas
positif il nous reste d'ailleurs à faire
que se passe soit conforté et nous
engageons d'ailleurs une nouvelle
campagne de communication de nouveau
cette année pour que les
identifie bien qu'elle porte ils doivent
pousser pour avoir ce renseignement et
pour vous donner aussi un autre chiffre
plus de 50% des gens qui poussent la
porte de France rénove avec un projet
repartent avec un projet différent
c'est-à-dire il y a effectivement cette
accompagnement qui est totalement
objectif nous n'avons aucun intérêt à
privilégier tel ou tel artisan
évidemment tel ou tel geste mais plutôt
les amener celles et ceux qui rentrent
les ménages à se poser la question de
qu'est-ce qui est vraiment pertinent et
pas forcément
les conforter dans ce qu'il propose pour
cela qu'on leur demande par exemple
d'annuler les plans soit de la maison
soit de l'habitation pour que la
personne qui soit là le technicienne le
technicien puisse effectivement leur
dire nous vous suggérons bon après cela
appartient mais plus de 50% reparte avec
un projet différent après leur passé en
quelque sorte pour analyser chacune et
chacun la situation dans laquelle ils
inscrivent leur projet de transformation
de logement
alors est-ce que nos collègues ont des
questions à poser non moi je voulais
j'aurais voulu qu'on me fassiez un petit
peu plus un bilan et un focus sur la ma
prime rénov copro donc vous avez dit que
c'est un dispositif qui commence à
monter en puissance voilà est-ce que
vous pouvez un petit peu nous en dire un
peu plus et comment envoyer les choses
évoluer au niveau des copropriétés
alors ce que l'on constate sont
effectivement
les chiffres que le président de Lana
vous indiquait tout à l'heure je les
reprends moi-même d'ailleurs je me
permets de vous dire que nous vous
adresserons enfin un tableau
récapitulatif qui permet de voir la
Renault globale
par année et son évolution donc 7000
logements autour de qui ont bénéficié de
ma prime rénov copro en 2020 l'année
voilà
c'était le début 12000 en 2021 et 25000
en 2022 donc on voit effectivement
une évolution qui est quasiment un
doublement enfin en tout cas entre 2021
et 2022 un doublement
qui montre une répartition aussi au
début c'était essentiellement des
copropriétés dites fragiles qui
sollicitaient parce que tout le monde
connaissait habiter mieux copro qui
était destiné uniquement aux copropriété
fragile et en fait depuis l'année 2022
on est on est en équilibre c'est à dire
50% des copropriétés qui ont sollicité
cette aide sont des copropriétés
fragiles 50 les 50 autres % sont des
copropriétés qui ne sont pas fragiles
donc saines enfin qui ne connaissent pas
en tout cas derrière Ray Charles ou d'un
pays de charge
autre élément important c'est que le
cette aide à fortement évolué suite au
conseil d'administration de la fin de
l'année de la fin de l'année 2022 donc
de décembre 2022 puisque le plafond de
travaux était à 15000 euros il a été
augmenté à 25000 euros
donc depuis le 1er janvier pour pouvoir
répondre à un certain nombre
d'observations d'opérateurs ou de
spécialistes de la copropriété qui nous
faisait remonter de façon très objective
les difficultés qu'il pouvait rencontrer
en fait en assemblée générale par
rapport à des difficultés donc ce
plafond de travaux a été réhaussé et par
ailleurs les primes au ménage modestes
et très modestes ont été doublés pour
les ménages modestes elle était la prime
était à 750 euros elle est passée à 1500
euros et pour très modeste elle était à
1500 euros et elle est passée à 3000
euros c'est à dire c'est une prime
supplémentaire qui est vraiment dédiée
au ménage des quatre premiers des cils
de la population pour leur permettre de
gravir encore un une étape
supplémentaire par rapport à un reste à
charge puisque je le rappelle c'est
l'aide de ma prime rénov copropriété est
une aide à tous les copropriétaires quel
que soit leur niveau de ressources et
quel que soit leur statut en fait
propriétaire occupant ou propriétaire
bailleur et d'ailleurs quel que soit la
taille du logement aussi donc voilà il y
a une prime vraiment dédiée en fait au
ménage aux ressources les plus les plus
faibles pour avoir un effet levier
supplémentaire dans leur prise de
décision donc aujourd'hui on est on
examine enfin c'est tôt ce que je
citerai pas de chiffres parce que ce
sont des chiffres qui pour l'instant se
concrétisent pas mais ce qu'on a vu
depuis le début de l'année enfin dans le
cours de ce premier trimestre 2023 c'est
un nombre de créations de comptes autour
de ma prime rénove qui est quasiment le
double de ce que nous avions l'an
dernier exactement à la même date
mais pour l'instant ce sont des
créations de comptes qui ne se sont pas
encore transformés en demande évidemment
de subventions puisque nous avons deux
grandes périodes de demandes de
subvention sur ma prime rénov
copropriété une en général vers le
printemps début de l'été et surtout une
plus importante à l'automne après les
assemblées générales en fait
essentiellement qui prennent les
décisions de s'engager dans des
démarches de travaux autre élément
important c'est que cette aide au fond
une fois parce que j'ai entendu on a
entendu beaucoup de choses là dessus une
fois que la demande de subvention est
posée elle est gravée dans le marbre
c'est-à-dire que même si notre
réglementation était amenée à évoluer à
partir du moment où une demande a lieu
par exemple en octobre 2023 même si la
réglementation évoluait en 2024-2025
pendant que les travaux sont en train de
se réaliser dans la copro puisqu'on sait
que c'est des travaux de longue haleine
de toute façon la subvention telle
qu'elle a été notifiée en fait au
conseil syndical ne changera pas elle ne
changerait que si le programme de
travaux évidemment évolu et que les
factures ne soient pas conformes aux
devis qui ont été présentés aux demandes
au moment de la demande de subvention
donc ça c'est aussi un élément de
sécurisation en fait par rapport à ce
collectif que constitue le syndicat de
copropriétaire qui est évidemment très
pluriel et très très multiple et qui a
besoin d'être rassuré par rapport à ça
et ce qui est un grand changement par
rapport au crédit d'impôt qui justement
évoluait et pouvait changer et en plus
dépendait de chaque de chaque situation
et de chaque ménage voilà et puis enfin
dernier élément c'est majoritairement et
essentiellement et uniquement même des
travaux de rénovation globale donc qui
embarquent des travaux de rénovation
globale concernant les parties communes
donc qui embarquent de l'isolation une
transformation du système de chauffage
et bien souvent la ventilation sous
réserve bien entendu que le chauffage
soit un chauffage collectif si bien sûr
on est sur une copropriété avec autant
de chauffage individuels c'est une autre
histoire et dans ces cas-là on mixte des
aides
on mixte l'aide ma prime rénov
copropriété avec des aides individuelles
par ménage pour ce qui concerne la
réalisation des travaux dans leur
logement
par exemple géographiquement vous pouvez
voir s'il y a les territoires qui sont
plus allant que d'autres ou qu'est-ce
qui peut je sais pas si vous avez la
possibilité d'avoir ces données de voir
s'il y a des territoires qui sont plus
engagés que d'autres et pour quelle
raison d'après vous est-ce que c'est que
des questions de climat ou pas je sais
pas alors on a des données bien sûr
géographiques qu'on pourra partager avec
vous je suis pas sûr que ces données
soient définitivement parlantes mais en
revanche on voit bien que dans les
agglomérations dans les métropoles dans
enfin voilà dans les secteurs
urbains en fait où on a beaucoup de
copropriétés et notamment dans des
territoires et où les collectivités se
sont engagés finalement dans des
opérations programmées d'amélioration de
l'habitat tourner avec un volet
copropriété et qui ont commencé
uniquement maintenant à se saisir de ma
prime rénov copropriété ouverte à toutes
les copropriétés on voit bien que
l'apport de la collectivité à la fois
dans le suivi animation dans les
réunions de concertation qui peuvent
être organisées par quartier et bien
entendu dans l'aide supplémentaire que
va apporter la collectivité territoriale
c'est un véritable effet levier et c'est
plutôt dans ces territoires qu'on voit
cette évolution à la hausse
mais pas que mais c'est quand même
l'élément prégnant mais on vous
transmettra ces éléments bien sûr
rajouter un ou deux petits éléments
complémentaires parce que c'est ce que
dit valérie mancatel est important sur
le fait que ce soit des rénovations
globales ça répondait à votre
interrogation tout à l'heure donc avec
au moins 35 % de gains à la clé en
matière
énergétique ce qui est vrai aussi que
lorsque la collectivité locale elle-même
participe parfois des avec des
subventions ça aide d'autant plus que si
c'est le cas Lana elle-même major son
taux de subvention donc il y a un effet
boule de neige qui est intéressant et
qui parfois fait le déclic vous savez
comment c'est difficile les assemblées
générales de copropriété c'est un monde
à part entière où les intérêts des uns
des autres ne sont pas forcément les
mêmes entre un propriétaire occupant un
propriétaire bailleur un
multipropriétaires ce que ce que l'on
voit et je pense que on a alimenté en
puissance d'ailleurs nous avions on l'a
pas dit je crois dans le budget 23 on a
anticipé qu'il y a plus de 40 000
logements puisqu'on parle de leurs 25000
ans en 22 on a fait le pari aura plus de
40 000 je suis sûr qu'on y arrivera et
qu'on le dépassera probablement pourquoi
parce que il y a cette prise de
conscience d'une certaine nombre de nos
concitoyens sur la question
environnementale je pense qu'on est aidé
aussi par l'évolution des prix de
l'énergie ça contribue aussi à prendre
des décisions et puis vous avez enfin le
Parlement l'État ont pris un certain
nombre de dispositions qui font que
bientôt la location d'un certain nombre
de logements qui ne correspondent plus à
des critères énergétiques ne pourront
plus être loués ensuite ils ne pourront
peut-être vendus sous réserve de faire
des travaux et tout cela lié fait que
notamment dans les copropriétés
aujourd'hui les choses bougent et je le
dis on est sorti ensuite de la aussi de
la phase de covid qui a été quand même
très très péjorante pour les prises de
décision en copropriété sur les travaux
merci à vous pour l'intérêt que vous
portez à Lana